right why should women shouldn't vote
yes yes okay a lot of people think I'm
insane because I don't think women
should vote everybody thinks I'm crazy
for this opinion if anything this is
probably my most extreme opinion and I
would like to tell you how I came to
this conclusion so what happened I
wanted to know why men were so angry
about
why are there
then I started researching the stuff it
was pretty easy to figure out why ninety
percent of women have been on birth
control one out of three women has had
an one out of three women has an STD
average body count is over five so that
your average wife has slept with over
five people 95 percent of women are not
virgins on their wedding days so I
understand the complaint now